Speaker 1: Well, another woman has come forward
and says Herschel Walker paid for one of my
abortions as well. And the question we have at
this time is, does this even matter to the very
same Republican voters who say abortion is
the most important issue to them? Background
on this. Some weeks ago, Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker had a woman come forward
and say, hey, you know what? He publicly says?
No exceptions for abortion. Nothing, nothing,
nothing. Always against it because it's murder.
But he urged me to get and paid for an abortion
for me some years ago. And then later, when he
got me pregnant again, he tried to get me to have
another abortion. But that time I refused. And he
is the father of one of my children. This was one
woman, Herschel Walker denied it with very little
credibility, admitting that, yes, he did send a
check to the woman, but it was for the kid they
had together, even though he sent the check years
before that kid was born. Completely unbelievable.
Any sensible person looks at the facts and says,
Of course, Herschel Walker paid for this
woman's abortion. It's very, very clear.
Another woman has now come forward and said
Herschel Walker impregnated me and also
urged me to get and paid for an abortion.
That woman known currently as Jane Doe is
represented by attorney Gloria Allred. And let's
listen to a little bit of the press conference
yesterday. This is, again, a second woman.
Speaker 2: Our client alleges that Mr. Walker
gave her cash to pay for the abortion and
that she went to a clinic in Dallas, Texas.
However, while she was at the clinic,
she became overwhelmed with emotion.
She could not go through with it, and she left
the clinic in tears. When Mr. Walker called that
night, our client told him what had happened and
that she had not gone through with the abortion.
He was upset. He pressured her to go back to the
clinic with him the next day to go through with
the abortion. The following day, Mr. Walker drove
her to the clinic and waited in the parking lot
for hours until the abortion was completed
and she came out. Then he drove her to the
pharmacy to pick up medications and supplies
as prescribed, and then he drove her home.
In the days following the abortion, Mr. Walker
began to distance himself from our client. She
was very distraught because she felt that Mr.
Walker had pressured her into having an abortion.
She left Dallas after she moved out of
Dallas. Mr. Walker sent our client a note
apologizing for what he had put her through.
As you will hear from my client, Jane Doe, she
has come forward at this time because she feels
that it's important that the truth comes out.
Speaker 1: So you get the sense and the picture
of what's going on here. There is another
moment at which Gloria Allred presents
what is alleged to be a photo of Herschel
Walker in the bed of Jane Doe's hotel room.
Speaker 2: This is a photo of Herschel Walker in
our client's hotel room. Some of it. This once
again, this is Minnesota.
Speaker 1:
Okay. And then we also heard by voice
from the woman herself talking about
what happened and making it clear that she's
a Trump voter. This is not political for her.
Speaker 2: I am a registered independent. And
I voted for Donald Trump in both elections.
I do not believe that Hershel is
morally fit to be a U.S. senator.
Speaker 1: That's clear.
Speaker 2: And that is the reason
why I am speaking up and providing proof.
Speaker 1: So the question, of course, is,
is this going to matter when we look at the
polling in this race? It is a dead heat.
Half a point on average separates Raphael
Warnock, the incumbent Democratic senator,
and Herschel Walker. Walker is a liar. Walker is
incompetent. Walker has no business being even
in this race. But because of what has happened
to this country, because of what has happened
to the Georgia Republican electorate. Herschel
Walker may be the next senator from Georgia,
which is an incredible, incredible thing. If
you vote in Georgia, there are just days to
go. 12 days, right? Is that where we are? Let me
see here. Seven. And that, yeah, 12 days with 12
days to go. We've got to do everything we can
to prevent a dangerously unqualified individual
from becoming the next senator from Georgia.
Let's go now to Herschel Walker's reactions